As the official name of Paris–Bordeaux–Paris
Trail suggests, the idea of this particular
event was to see who could drive from Paris
to Bordeaux and back again in the quickest
possible time.
For reference, this was a distance of 1,178
km or 732 miles on the roads of the day.
So what was so special about this particular
race?
Well, for the first time in history, a large
group of automobiles would be pitted against
one another in a first to finish-style event,
with said race kicking off on June 11, 1895.
The brainchild of a group of automobile enthusiasts
and journalists keen to promote the then fledgling
French automobile industry, the race was seen
as a way to both test the limits of cars at
the time as well as test the commercial viability
of motor racing as a spectator sport.
Although, as we’ve previously noted, this
was only a couple decades after an era in
which competitive walking was one of the world’s
most popular spectator sports, so the competition
was pretty light.
And, to be perfectly clear- we’re not talking
speed walking- just regular leisurely walking
for hours and hours on end…
In fact, certain walking matches were known
to draw tens of thousands of spectators.
Yes, before YouTube, our forebears found watching
people casually walking in circles for sometimes
days on end without stopping great entertainment,
though to be fair this was probably really
just an ideal excuse to get together and socialize.
To tie it back to cars, in some respects this
is not too dissimilar from NASCAR, but without
the occasional flaming crashes.
In any event, previous to the Paris–Bordeaux–Paris
Trail others had variously raced individual
cars against one another, with perhaps the
first such race occurring on August 30, 1867
where a steam powered car built by Isaac Watt
Boulton, driven by his son, competed in an
eight mile race against one of Daniel Adamson’s
steam cars, with the driver in the latter
case not known today.
More significantly, in 1878 in the United
States, the Wisconsin Legislature attempted
to organize a 200 mile race for self propelled
vehicles, but only two vehicles ended up entering.
Slightly more humorously in 1887 in Paris
a two kilometer race was organized by a local
paper, but only one person, one Georges Bouton
of the De Dion-Bouton Company, entered.
Naturally, he won…
Moving closer to what we’d today consider
an automobile race was an event that took
place in Paris in 1894- the Paris-Rouen Rally.
However, while this is sometimes called the
actual first car race, it should be noted
that, beyond the organizers of the event explicitly
noting it was not a race in a December of
1893 edition of the Le Petit Journal describing
the event, the winner was not the car that
crossed the finish line first.
Rather, the winner was decided by a panel
of judges based on the overarching criteria
of which car was closest to “ideal”, with
ideal here referring to the car that was simultaneously
relatively cheap to purchase and operate,
most reliable, and easiest and safest to drive.
Towards that end, while the order of finishing
the course was considered in determining the
winner, the car that crossed the finish line
first was not given 1st place as it needed
a second person to ride along to stoke the
flames to keep it going.
Instead, the first prize of 5,000 francs (extremely
roughly between about $30,000 to $400,000
today depending on what inflation metric you
want to use) was shared between two companies,
most notable for the story at hand, one of
which being Panhard et Levassor.
This brings us to about a year later and the
Paris-Bordeaux-Paris Trail competition.
In this event, the winning car was intended
to be the one that completed the circuit first,
with a few stipulations.
First, any winning car was required to have
more than two seats.
Second, while mid-race repairs and maintenance
were allowed, they could only be performed
with materials stored in the vehicle itself.
On top of this, drivers were allowed to switch
out as often as they liked.
Finally, largely to stop manufacturers flooding
the race with their own vehicles to pad the
odds in their own favor, it was ruled that
manufactures could only enter one of each
type of vehicle they produced.
In total, some 23 automobiles entered the
race, only 9 of which would finish the arduous
journey between the cities, with eight of
those being ICE vehicles (internal combustion
engine) and the ninth being a seven seater
steam car.
On top of gas and steam powered automobiles,
there was even an all electric car entered-
yes, contrary to popular perception, electric
cars actually dominated the automobile world
in the earliest days of the industry.
For example, in New York City in 1899 approximately
90% of all taxi cabs were electric cars, mostly
built by Electric Carriage and Wagon Company
of Philadelphia.
Not only that, but in 1899 and 1900, electric
cars outsold all other types of automobiles.
In 1902 an electric car, the Baker Torpedo,
became the first car to have an aerodynamic
body that enclosed both the driver and the
platform.
This car at one point reached a then astounding
80 mph in a speed test before crashing and
killing two spectators.
It was later clocked as high as 120 mph, but
with spectators not invited this time…
The popularity of electric vehicles at the
time is easy to understand.
The electric cars had no excessive vibrations
from the engine and were extremely quiet compared
to its competitors.
They also didn’t emit smoke or backfire
frequently as did gas powered cars.
They were also ready to go right when you
sat in the car, unlike gas powered cars that
needed to be cranked by hand to start; this
was not only difficult, but also could be
dangerous.
Steam powered cars, on the other hand, typically
required a half an hour to an hour to get
going on cold days.
The other large advantage with electric cars
was not having to change gears (once those
were introduced), which was a hard thing to
do in early incarnations of clutch/gearbox
systems.
The only real advantage that gas powered cars
had at this time were the long ranges they
were capable of with larger tanks and the
ability to fill up quickly when the tank was
empty.
However, because at the time there weren’t
a lot of well developed roads for cars to
drive on safely, most people only drove cars
in cities anyways, so range wasn’t a huge
factor.
(Hybrid cars would soon after be invented
as roads started making long distance automobile
travel more accessible, but largely thanks
to the likes of Henry Ford and his ultra-cheap
cars, it would be a long time before major
car companies would circle back around to
mass producing a hybrid or electric vehicle.)
In any event, as a result of the diversity
of power sources in the Paris-Bordeaux-Paris
race and the extreme length of the course,
it was also seen as a way of judging which
method of powering automobiles might be superior.
Soon after the race began, it became clear
to pretty much everyone involved that the
winner was going to be Émile Levassor’s
Panhard et Levassor car powered by a modified
four horsepower Daimler Phoenix engine.
The car was unique in several ways.
To begin with, it broke from tradition by
having the engine in front of the driver.
In experimenting with various positions, Levassor
found this to be superior via lengthening
the wheel base significantly, while also lowering
the center of gravity by having the passenger
not above the engine as was common, but closer
to the ground behind it.
In both cases, this made the car much less
likely to roll over, which was a bit of a
problem with many early cars, particularly
driving on less than perfect roads.
His design also sported a unique (for the
time) clutch system allowing Levassor to adjust
the vehicle’s gears easier on the fly.
It also featured a front mounted water radiator,
massively improving the reliability of the
engine compared to most others that simply
relied on natural air cooling.
On top of this, he got rid of the bicycle
style belt drive and went with a crankshaft
and connecting hardware to the rear differential.
This novel layout and general design (front
engine/rear wheel drive), which would soon
be copied by pretty much every car manufacturer
would, ironically, come to be known as the
Systeme Panhard, presumably because Panhard’s
name came first in the pair’s company name,
even though Levassor, not his business partner
Rene Panhard, is generally credited as being
the one who actually came up with most of
the innovations.
In any event, this general design made Levassor’s
car not only extremely reliable, even over
continuous use for hours at a time, but also
much more agile, giving Levassor a clear edge
over his opponents.
Within an hour, Levassor was easily leading
the race and arrived in Bordeux so far ahead
of his opponents that his co-driver, who was
supposed to drive the second half of the race,
was still asleep in his hostel.
In fact, because he had arrived so much sooner
than anyone expected, the officials he needed
to notify about his arrival were also sleeping.
After being unable to discern which hotel
his co-driver was staying in, Levassor decided
to just wake up the race officials so they
could verify he’d been there, then drove
back to Paris on his own, setting off at around
2:30AM after having a short walk and a glass
of champagne and a sandwich.
After driving for 48 hours and 47 minutes
without sleeping, Levassor arrived in Paris,
including stopping time averaging a breakneck
pace of about 15 mph (24.1 km/h).
He noted upon his arrival, “Some 50 km before
Paris I had a rather luxurious snack in a
restaurant which helped me.
But I feel a little tired.”
As such, after officials acknowledge his finish,
he went off to bed.
About six hours later, Levassor was awoken
by an official who told him that the person
in second place, Louis Rigoulot, had finally
arrived.
Five hours after this, both men greeted the
man who finished third- Paul Koechlin.
Unfortunately for Levassor and Rigoulot, when
scrutinizing the exact wording of the rules,
officials realized that the “two seat”
stipulation was not inclusive as in “two
or more seats” but required that the car
have more than two seats.
Because of this, Levassor and Rigoulot were
summarily disqualified as their vehicles only
had two seats- something that perhaps should
have been looked at closer before the racers
set out.
Unsurprisingly, this caused a great deal of
confusion and outrage amongst both automobile
enthusiasts and the many thousands who’d
gathered to watch the race and clearly saw
Levassor win by a massive margin.
As such, the race had the intended effect
for his and Panhard’s company, with Levassor
generally considered the winner by the teeming
masses, even though Koechlin, in his four
seater car, walked away with the prize.
To avoid a similar controversy in future,
the rules of future races were changed so
that the winner of a race was whomever crossed
the finish line first…
In 1897 Levassor would compete in the Paris-Marseille-Paris
race.
Unfortunately for him he not only didn’t
win this race, but he seemingly died because
of it.
You see, while traveling at high speed down
a hill, a dog ran out in front of his car.
Not wanting to run over the animal, Levassor
swerved, resulting in the vehicle flipping
over.
He initially survived the event and even attempted
to finish the race, but had to stop, not because
his car failed him, but his body.
Unfortunately a broken rib and internal injuries
saw the 54 year old’s health rapidly decline
over the following months.
He died of a coronary embolism while sitting
at his desk trying to design a magnetic clutch
in April of 1897.
The Michelin brothers, André and Edouard,
also competed in the Paris-Bordeaux race in
one of their company’s cars.
They did not manage to finish in the 100 hour
timeslot, however.
What makes their entry significant, and somewhat
foreshadowing what their company would soon
be better known for, is that they were running
on pneumatic tires, a rather unique feature
on automobiles of the day, many of which were
more or less just using steel banded wood
wagon wheels.
Humorously, the Michelin car, dubbed the Lightning,
was not named such because it was faster than
others per se, but rather because its steering
mechanism was so bad that it ultimately traveled
in something of a zig-zag pattern…